So, you're inspired and want to try your
hands at choreographing a poi or poi
dance piece. Congratulations. You've got
a long road ahead of you, and some steps
are going to be more challenging than
others, but one of the most challenging
ones is usually one of the first ones.
How do you select music that you
choreograph to? What song should you
pick, and what considerations should go
into that choice? Friends, I've got you
covered. Let's dive into choosing the
song that's going to be the best fit for
your work.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
take you through some thoughts on how
you should go about selecting music to
choreograph to. But before we dive in, I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel. Big thanks
to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests,
Flow Toys, Paroter, Light Toys, and
Ultraoy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible. You can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-b businessiness friend of the
channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank you so
very much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. So, it needs to be
said up front that choreographing is
really hard any way you look at it. And
music can be one of those things that
adds to those difficulties. Pick a song
that nobody likes, and it might mean
that they have similar feelings about
the piece you write to it. Pick one with
the wrong vibe, and the whole piece
might not work. At least, these are
things that you might be telling
yourself walking into it. The good news
is that in the grand scheme of things,
this isn't as big a choice as you think
it is. But at the same time, there are
some considerations, both practical and
artistic, that go into a project like
this. I've got a list of five that I'd
like to share, but they are by no means
the last word on how you make this
choice. Just some guidelines to get you
started. So, let's dive in.
Number one, match the setting.
In determining what music to use for
choreographing a piece, it's helpful to
review what exactly this choreography is
going to be used for. Is this something
you're writing for a gig? something
you're going to bring to a fire festival
or is it just for fun? If you're writing
for a gig, you should really make sure
your music fits the theme of the event.
Whether that be carnival, circ in the
club, or something else entirely, make
sure to pick out music that fits that
theme. There are lots of featured
Spotify playlists that can help you find
circus themed music, dramatic
instrumentals, European club music, and
everything in between. Browse through
them and see if you can find something
that you like. If you're bringing a
piece to a fire festival, a popular
option I've seen a lot of has been to
take instrumental versions of popular
top 40 or rock tracks or songs from
genres that are in underground scenes
that overlap with the flow arts. Think
up and coming EDM genres, metal, and
folk punk for a few. Once again, you can
find Spotify playlists for the genre of
your choice and pick out something you
think is a good fit for what you have in
mind. But what about if this
choreography is just going to be for
you? Well, then the music should also be
something that pleases you yourself. Do
you have a song that you just can't sit
still to? One that conjures wonderful
imagery to mind or really just sums up
the vibe you've been feeling lately.
Sounds like a great pick to me. And if
you have multiple songs that fit that
bill and you just can't choose between
them, then honestly, just pick one. You
can always do another one as a follow-up
if you like what you came up with.
Number two, don't be a hero. In
narrowing down song options for your
choreography, there is one really,
really big criteria that I think should
absolutely come into play as you're
making your choice, and that is song
length. Put simply, the longer the song
is, the longer it's going to take you to
choreograph a piece to it, and the more
exhausting it will be to rehearse that
choreography. In general, when you're
starting out, I'd say it's essential to
work with a song that's under 3 minutes.
And if possible, keep it under two.
Trust me, you will thank me for this
later, as this process takes so much
longer than you think it does. As time
goes on and you get more experience
writing choreography, you can try doing
it to longer pieces of music, and you'll
have the skills to get you through that
process. But if this is among the first
pieces you've ever written, then do
yourself a favor and don't be a hero.
This is also as good a place as any to
talk about how much of the song you want
to choreograph to. If this is just going
to Instagram or Tik Tok, there's a
reason they try to keep snippets of a
song to only 15 to 30 seconds. You don't
need everything to be a novel. And the
longer you go, the more likely both you
and the audience will get bored with it.
If, on the other hand, you're doing a
professional gig and a contract says you
have to fill a certain amount of time,
then it's time to buckle down and do the
thing. I've had performances that lasted
for just a couple minutes and others
that lasted upwards of 10. If you've got
enough ideas to fill up a full song,
then absolutely shoot for that. But
otherwise, there's no reason to drive
yourself crazy here. Keep it short and
sweet. Both you and your audience will
appreciate it.
Number three, matching the movements.
So, here's another big consideration in
choosing the music. How easy is it for
you to hear the beat in the song? Are
there long sections where it becomes
hard to keep track? Are there moments
when the performers are stretching
sections out that are a little hard to
follow? In general, you want to steer
towards songs that are a little bit more
consistent to follow because it's going
to make your job easier in keeping track
of when a music cue was coming up. I
have definitely performed to songs
that'll get quiet or drop out entirely
for a few seconds and finding my way
back, especially when I'm all hopped up
on the adrenaline of being on stage can
be a huge challenge. And missing that
cue can be really embarrassing. Set
yourself up for success and choose
something that won't have you stressing
out when the beat is finally going to
drop or what number of the count you
were on when the music got quiet. Unless
this song is one that you just
absolutely know backwards and forwards
like the back of your hand, don't leave
it up to chance. Go with something
consistent that's easy to follow. Number
four, the perils of earworms.
Okay, so more than likely you've got a
song in mind that you've listened to a
lot in the past. And that can be a good
thing because it's familiar and more
than likely other people know it and
like it too. But let me ask you this.
How do you feel about listening to it
over and over and over again for hours
on end? See, the thing to bear in mind
when you're writing choreography is that
it is a very time-consuming process. I
personally find that for every minute of
final choreography that I had to invest
at least an hour into writing the
choreography for it and countless others
rehearsing it. Even the most fun and
familiar song can come to be obnoxious
when it's all you've been listening to
for hours on end while working through
frustrating challenges in your coro. So,
how do you avoid this problem? Your
mileage may vary, but what I find is
that there's something of a bell curve
when it comes to music that I know and
like. On one end of the curve are songs
that are perennial favorites, songs that
I can listen to anytime and anywhere
regardless of my mood. I've had a
relationship with them for years and
will continue to for years into the
future. On the other end are songs that
I have a casual familiarity with. I know
nothing about the artists that sing
them, and I have very little investment
in them beyond just thinking that
they're pretty cool. It may seem kind of
counterintuitive, but I actually find
that the songs that work best for
choreographing are those that fit at
either of these ends of the spectrum. If
they're a longtime favorite, then I
don't mind listening to them for hours
on end, and working through them with
choreography can't change my
relationship with them. If I'm only
casually familiar with them, then I can
let them go as soon as the project is
done. I still listen to only a small
handful of songs I've choreographed to
over the years, and I'm good with that
fact. In the center are things like
super catchy earworms that everybody
knows. Avoid those like the plague. The
catchy bits that make them light and fun
will also make them beyond obnoxious
over time.
Number five, what moves you?
Okay, so when push comes to shove, I
think this is actually the single most
important consideration of all. Does
this song make you want to move?
Actually, let me back up a step. So, I
think there are actually two very
distinct but also important types of
choreography. The first is something
that more or less exists simply as a
demonstration. This is a popular option
for gigs and sometimes fire festivals
and all it requires is a song that's
easy to follow and has a specific tempo.
Technically, you don't even need music
to write this kind of choreography.
You're just putting together pieces to
show off and the music really isn't a
big component of that and there is
nothing wrong with that. At the other
end of the spectrum, there are pieces
you choreograph that are supposed to be
about something that are meant to have
an idea at their core and something that
you want to communicate through them.
And if you're creating that kind of
choreography, then you want to pick
music to back it that inspires you to
move. You want to choose music that you
have a hard time not moving to. That
inspiration will carry you through those
moments when writing or performing is
challenging. It'll help keep your
creative juices flowing and push you
onwards when you get stuck. For me
personally, the vast majority of what I
write falls into this category. I hear a
piece of music in the beat, the musical
flourishes, or the lyrics themselves
just set off something in my head where
I can already see what the movement is
supposed to be. This can also lead to a
great deal of frustration when you find
that your skills perhaps do not measure
up to the picture that you have in your
head, but that's a conversation for
another time. Above all, look for music
that awakens something inside of you
that wants to create and be seen. you'll
have a lot more fun and create much
better work as a result. So, how did you
like that list, friends? Were there
things that I left out? Questions you
still have? Leave me a comment and let
me know. Be sure to like, comment,
share, and subscribe to help other
people find this video and to help my
channel grow.
This video would not have been possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I want to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed up here on screen. Thank you all
so much for supporting my work. You too
can get your name listed up on screen
along with a host of other awesome
rewards when you sign up to support
these videos over on Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
Help me bring pois spinning and flowarts
to the whole wide world. Thank you in
advance. And if you'd like to learn more
about choreographing without music, you
should check out this other video I did
on that topic at the link down in the
description or up on screen. Thank you
so much for watching. Make sure you get
out and flow yourself today. And I'll
see you with a new video real soon. Take
care now. Peace.